in the game of Thrones TV show euron
greyjoy is a violent shit-talking pirate
who wants to [ __ ] the Queen and rule the
world but in the book series Iran's a
totally different character he's a scary
manipulative murderer a charismatic
politician and a psychedelic sorcerer
hungry for apocalyptic power he's got a
magic dragon horn and warlocks slaves
and Valyrian steel armor he's connected
to the mysterious magic of bloodraven
the faceless men and Valyria urine
doesn't just want a throne he wants
cosmic eldritch power and plans a
blasphemous blood sacrifice to make
himself a Lovecraftian God the fan
community especially poor Quentin
theorized that urine will bring
apocalypse
to Westeros at the start of the story
Balin Greyjoy rules the Iron Islands he
rebels against the Iron Throne and
declares the islands his own separate
Kingdom his daughter Asha and his son
Theon attacked the north Balin also has
three brothers Victarion is a warrior
he's strong and loyal and kinda stupid a
ron is a priest of the drowned God he
used to be a party boy until he was born
again as a religious man and then
there's you Ron crows I Euron was exiled
from the islands years ago and has since
been sailing far distant seas and his
infamous pirate ship and the silence its
crew are mutes with their tongues ripped
out
it sails a black and its decks are
painted red to hide the blood that soaks
them the silence is feared all across
the east from eeab to a shy but urine
doesn't appear in the story right away
he's introduced slowly like the monster
in a horror movie with just rumors and
memories to build tension and mystery
men say terrible things of euron greyjoy
Victarion and a ron hate and fear you
Ron hey Ron thanks the storm is coming
and it's name is Euron crows I in book
three King Balin suddenly dies he falls
to his death from a bridge on Pike and
the very next day
Euron returns after years away
and claims Palin's throne it's very
suspicious
so Asha thinks that you are on murdered
bail on in the TV show Euron does
straight up murder bail on but in the
books it's more complicated iya meets a
witch called the ghost of hai Hart who
makes a bunch of accurate predictions
and prophecies and the witch sees a man
without a face on a bridge that sways
and swings on his shoulder perches a
drowned crow with seaweed hanging from
his wings presumably the man without a
face is an assassin of the faceless men
and the drowned crow is Euron crows eye
meaning that Euron hired a faceless man
to kill bail on hiring a faceless
assassin is expensive especially if the
target is someone important like King
Balin but it's implied that you can pay
the faceless man with something other
than money if you sacrifice something
that's important to you Joran claims
that he once had a dragon egg he tried
to make it hatch but got frustrated and
threw the egg in the sea dragon eggs are
super valuable and rare so would urine
really throw one away some fans believe
that urine actually gave the egg to the
faceless men as payment so that they
would throw bail on in the sea one way
or another
Iran secretly hired a magical assassin
to murder his own brother but publicly
he hides his evil behind a charismatic
persona the real Iran is hidden which is
symbolized by Iran's eyepatch his right
eye is described as his smiling eye the
charming swaggering magnanimous side but
the eye behind his eyepatch is his blood
eye where he hides his full cruelty than
sorcery and ambition by the time the
Ironborn see Euron's true face it's too
late
after King Balin dies the Ironborn hold
a king's mood to choose a new king and
Huron uses a combination of politics
murder and swag to win the driftwood
crown he rolls up in his infamous ship
the silence with an entourage of mutes
monsters and wizards from the east he
hands out treasure from his years of
piracy bribing some rivals and murdering
others he makes grin
Oh speeches about how badass he is how
he's raided raped and looted all over
the world which is the kind of thing the
Ironborn respect in his election speech
Iran says he'll make the Iron Islands
great again evoking their glorious past
as conquerors he shows off his magic
horn dragon binder and says it has the
power to bind dragons to his will Iran
plans to sail across the world to marine
and to steal Daenerys Targaryen z--
dragons and to use them to take over
Westeros it's a totally crazy plan so
naturally the Ironborn love it and make
Iran their king
urine leads the Ironborn to conquer some
nearby islands cementing his power by
giving them some glory but privately
urine doesn't care about these islands
or about the Ironborn he cares only
about himself and everyone else is just
a means to an end
Iran wants the world he wants dragons
and whoa and he wants to marry Daenerys
when the Kraken weds the dragon let all
the world beware
so Euron sends his brother Victarion
with dragon binder to fetch Daenerys
Victarion hates hearin because years ago
urine had sex with the carians wife then
because of Victorians [ __ ] up male
pride Victorian beat his wife to death
missus why urine was exiled
so Victorian agrees to sail east but he
secretly plans to take Daenerys for
himself as a revenge for yer on taking
his wife but yer on knows all about
Victorians resentment and hatred and he
exploits these feelings to manipulate
Victorian Victorians like a puppet blind
to the tentacles that grasp him so he'll
probably fail to outsmart Iran we're
told that dragon binder brings dragons
not to the person who blows the horn but
to the horns true master and Euron is
the master here so one way or another it
looks likely the Victorian will die so
that Euron can get a Daenerys Iran might
steal the dragon Viserion like the night
king does in the TV show so this is how
Iran operates he exploits people's hopes
and fears to make
his slaves in his quest for power and
whoa
Iran uses and abuses his family and his
people and now he wants the world but
how did Yeon Greyjoy an Ironborn Reaver
become obsessed with dragons and world
domination
how did yeon become the crows i urine
says that when he was a boy he dreamed
that he could fly when he woke his
master said he couldn't fly but what if
he lied maybe we all can fly how will we
know unless we leap from some tall tower
this story is almost identical to how
bran stark discovers magic when bran is
a boy he falls from a tall tower then he
dreams that he can fly the three-eyed
crow visits his dream and opens brans
third eye to his magic when bran wakes
up he can't fly his master says he can't
learn magic but the maester is wrong and
bran learns magic from the three-eyed
crow aka Bloodraven who is way creepier
in the books so these flying dream
stories are too similar to be a
coincidence
blood Raven is called the three-eyed
crow and Euron is called the crows I
blood Raven has one red eye and Euron
sigil is one red eye with crows so the
theory goes that neuron like bran was
visited in his dreams by the three-eyed
crow in bronze dream he sees the bones
of a thousand other dreamers so it looks
like blood Raven has tried out a bunch
of potential students but most failed or
died maybe Euron was one of those
students
maybe when Bloodraven visited Euron's
dreams he saw how crazy and cruel Iran
is and decided not to teach him magic
but the damage was done
Iran went rogue with his third eye
opened
Bloodraven and bran are greenseers with
the power to skin change to enter the
mind of another creature we don't know
if Iran has that power but it would make
sense if he did cuz Euron gives
Victarion
a mute duskie woman to go east with him
and fans speculate that she's spying for
you
like maybe you Ron is skin changing into
her from afar to see what Victorians up
to skin changing a human is seen as an
evil abominable act so it's exactly the
sort of thing that Euron might do skin
changing might also explain how urine
controls his mute crew on the silence
like how else could you coordinate the
crew of a ship who can't talk and skin
changing isn't just a stock thing we're
told that some iron bones can change
into sea creatures so Huron might just
be a skin-changer bran and Bloodraven
can also magically enter people's dreams
and after urine says he'll marry
Daenerys Daenerys has a creepy sex dream
of a man with blue bruised lips
Iran has blue bruised lips because of a
drug he takes so that's probably him in
her dream Iran also enters a Ron's dream
later on so it's just speculation but
Iran might secretly have the magic
powers of a green seer either way a
visit from the three-eyed crow could
explain Iran's motivations in bronze
flying dream he sees the whole world
spread out below him he sees Winterfell
and ash I sees dragons and the heart of
winter
maybe you Ron saw the same things and
when he saw dragons and magic and the
whole world spread out below him he
wanted it all
Euron tasted godlike magic power
and ever since he'll stop at nothing to
get more iran travels to some of the
most magic and mysterious places in the
world he says he sailed to a shy by the
shadow right at the edge of the map and
saw wonders and terrors beyond imagining
lots of the most powerful sorcerers in
the story learned magic in a shy
Melisandre quaithe Marwan Meera Mazda
all went there a Shia is like Hogwarts
for edge Lords full of shadow binders
and blood mages casting dark spells in
the night and right by a shy is stick
guy the mysterious heart of darkness
where even shadow binders fear to tread
maybe Euron dared to enter the corpse
city and found some evil power their
urine also
he sailed to Valyria the smoking demon
haunted ruins of the ancient dragon
Lords people say it's impossible to
visible area and survived but urine does
have that Valyrian steel armor and that
Valyrian horn the old Valyrian Empire he
used dragons and slavery to conquer the
world which might have inspired Iran to
do the same thing
so it seems that after urine dreamed
that he could fly he traveled the world
in search of magic power and developed
his ambitions for world domination
at some point urine captured some
warlocks from calf the warlocks had just
been defeated by Daenerys and they were
out to get revenge but urine captured
them and took their shade of the evening
shade of the evening is a psychedelic
drug that gives visions of pasts and
futures urine got really into the shade
to the point where it stains his lips
blue and bruised urine says that the
shade opens his eyes that there's more
truth in it than in all the gods of
Earth urine believes that gods and
morality are lies and he commits
horrific crimes just to prove that no
God can stop him it's revealed that
Euron murdered three of his own brothers
as well as Baylin he killed Harlan and
Robin Greyjoy when they were young the
Ironborn seek in slaying as the most
evil crime so after you Ron choked the
life from Harlan he pissed into the sea
waiting for a God to strike him down and
none did gods are lies he says and men
are mate by breaking the laws of gods
and men Euron feels like a god himself
so you're on constantly mocks and
perverts everything that people hold
sacred he kin slays blasphemes breaks
every taboo just because he can it turns
out that the reason why a Ron is so
afraid of Iran is that when they were
young Iran sexually abused him Iran says
he taught Iran how to pray because Iran
would pray in terror when Euron came to
visit in the night
Iran learned that sadistic cruelty gets
him worship when he terrorizes the east
in a silence murdering and raping
men pray and so Huron says he is the
godliest man ever to raise sale if all
gods are lies Iran decides to become his
own God and to become a God he needs
blood the fasiqun is a chapter from the
upcoming winds of winter read at a
convention by George Martin and it's one
of the darkest most terrifying chapters
in the series Iran imprisons Iran and
tortures him physically and
psychologically he forces him to drink
shade of the evening and Iran has
nightmarish visions of dead brothers and
dead gods
Iran appears and says these are the last
days when the world shall be broken and
remade a new God shall be born from the
graves and charnel pits Iran's hidden
blood I is finally revealed in all of
its horror and ambition I am your king
he says I am your God after the vision
we see you on imprisoning priests of all
different religions as well as Iran he
has priests of the seven with their
tongues ripped out he has a red priest
with a burned off face he rips the legs
off a warlock and he has this girl
called folia
iran seduces valia and impregnates her
and says she'll be his wife and she's
happy and excited but then iran rips out
her tongue iran ties folia and iran and
the priests to the front of his ships as
you ron and the Ironborn sail into
battle against an enemy flate blood is
power in this world there's magic in
death and sacrifice so Iran plans a
blasphemous Massacre of unimaginable
scale this battle will kill his
imprisoned priests and his brother and
kill Fage and their unborn child it'll
kill the enemy fleet and probably his
own fleet in a catastrophic orgy of
death Iran dreams of Ironborn ships
burning on a boiling blood red sea this
carnage might summon Krakens from the
deep in Iran's vision Krakens come at
you Ron's command and were told that
Krakens can be drawn to the water's
surface by
blood these visions show a blood red sea
but urine wants this massacre to make
him a God he knows that death and fear
give him power and prayers he knows
there's magic in the holy blood of
priests and in the Kings blood of his
unborn child this battle is a giant
blood magic ritual
Euron will gorge on the deaths of
thousands to transform into a terrible
godlike baying mokoro says a toll and
twisted thing with one black eye and ten
long arms sailing on a sea of blood
Aaron says Euron as no longer human more
squid than man his face a mass of
writhing tentacles
so basically Cthulhu may be the drowned
God that the Ironborn worship is
actually an eldritch monster and Euron's
blood sacrifice will wake it from
ageless slumber or maybe urine really
did throw that dragon egg into the sea
and all this magic blood will make it
hatch into a monster a sea dragon there
is all sorts of crazy scary imagery here
and it's not clear exactly what will
happen but there will be blood and death
and horror which Euron thinks will give
him the godlike power to break and
remake the world and it's hinted that
he'll use this power against the city of
Old Town Euron's close to old town now
and his Ironborn have been raiding
towards the city Melisandre has a vision
of towers by the sea submerged beneath a
black and bloody tide rising from the
depths it makes sense that urine would
want old town because it's full of
secret magic Old Town's high tower is
built on an ancient foundation of
strange black stone which some say was
built by a Lovecraftian fish people
called the deep ones which connects to
the Cthulhu stove old town has the
citadel the University of the maesters
which holds magic Valyrian artifacts
called glass candles a faceless man just
infiltrated the Citadel possibly
searching for a secret blood-soaked tome
called the death of dragons the city is
ruled by the
Daten Hightower and his mad maid who for
the last 10 years have stayed in the
Hightower consulting books of spells
possibly to raise an army from the deep
old town is a powder keg of dormant
magic powers just waiting to explode
into an eldritch [ __ ] and Euron's
coming for it with a lit match sailing
on a sea of blood and the most dangerous
power in old town the one that could
spark apocalypse might be in the hands
of Sam Tarly in the books
there are legends of the Horn of winter
an ancient artifact with a power to
destroy the wall Mance Rayder claims to
have the horn but that turns out to be
fake so where is the true horn in book 2
John finds an old horn he gives it to
Sam who takes it to old town Sam and
John don't think this horns important
but the books keep subtly reminding us
that Sam has it so fans suspect that
Sam's horn at Old Town is the horn of
winter with the power to bring down the
wall and let the white walk it's in Iran
might want the white Walker apocalypse
Peep says he wants to break the world
and the Forsaken chapters full of
apocalyptic imagery Iran may have
learned about the White Walkers in his
flying dream just like when bran sees
the heart of winter at the end of the
world it said that the White Walkers
will bring a long night that never ends
and urines often described in terms of
night and darkness his hair is as black
as a midnight sea his sails are as black
as a starless sky he says we shall feast
before the fall of night at the Kings
moose urines dragon horn sounds three
times at the Nights Watch three horn
blasts means White Walkers calming Iran
may be the harbinger of apocalypse
according to Eastern legend the first
long night was caused by the bloodstone
Emperor and this ancient Emperor is very
similar to you Ron
the Emperor murdered his older sibling
to take her throne just like you Ron
murders Balin for his throne the Emperor
practiced dark
arts torture slavery and cannibalism
just like Iran practices Dark Arts
torture slavery and cannibalism the
emperor cast down the true gods like
Iran marks and attacks the gods and the
Emperor worshipped a creepy black stone
just like the Ironborn throne and the
Hightower foundation and the city of ash
I are all made of creepy black stone the
bloodstone Emperor married a tiger woman
which might be kind of like Iran wanting
to marry the dragon woman Daenerys the
sister who the Emperor aserp was called
the amethyst Empress and as urine points
out Daenerys has eyes are amethyst s--
neurons hidden eye is called his blood
eye which fits with the bloodstone
Emperor so there are lots of strong
connections between Iran and the
bloodstone Emperor the guy who caused
the first long night when the White
Walkers came for the first time it's all
happening again
when roderick the raider talks about
iran he warns that history is a wheel
and what has happened before will happen
again Iran is the bloodstone Emperor
born again a figure so addicted to power
and blasphemy that he'll bring darkness
to the world fan theorists pour Clinton
writes that urine will climb the high
tower in old town another tall tower and
will sound the horn of winter breaking
the wall bringing the night and sparking
the apocalypse and after the storm
they'll be silenced the game of thrones
book series is called a Song of Ice and
Fire
lots of Martyn stories are named after
songs because songs to him represent
life and love and memory Iran represents
the opposite of a song he is silenced
his ship is named silence he makes
people mutes he silences his brothers
with shame trauma and murder he brings
literal silence the first time he enters
the story a sudden silence falls and
when he leaves silence
lingers iran's apocalyptic ambitions
threatened to silence the Song of Ice
and Fire itself and sure the white
walkers are probably the true danger but
it's Euron who'll unleash them which
means the white walkers aren't just a
magical fantasy threat it's more like
climate change a threat that humans
bring onto themselves book 2 and book 3
in the series are called a Clash of
Kings and a Storm of Swords because
they're about war five Kings fight to
control Westeros and thousands of people
die for them but all of these Kings die
or fail so what did the war achieve book
4 explores the aftermath of war and it's
called a feast for crows because in the
end the only people who benefit from all
the death and chaos are they're outlaws
and opportunists they're monsters and
betrayers who exploit the war for their
own gain
like crows feasting on the corpse of
Westeros of the bloody Mama's raid and
rape Lady Stoneheart murders for
vengeance Littlefinger when the Bolton's
take over kingdoms and euron greyjoy
arises Westeros is dying he says those
who follow me shall feast until the end
of their days Euron crows I is the crow
of the book's title an embodiment of all
the greed cruelty and pride that drives
the conflict of the whole series because
like any politician Euron isn't
dangerous by himself we never see him
swing a sword or cast a spell urines
powerful because people are scared and
ignorant and greedy enough to follow him
the people chose him at the Kingsmoot
the Dark Lord was democratically elected
his evil is our evil his power comes
from the fear hope and hate inside us
that's how he manipulates his family his
people and the world and that's how
Westeros is reduced to corpses and crows
so you're on story isn't just about
dragons and Krakens though those bits
will be [ __ ] sick it's also about how
real human impulses lead us all into
self-destruction and silence
so TL DR that goofy pirate on the dragon
show who talks about fingers in balms is
actually the most scary smart magical
mysterious evil [ __ ] in Westeros
but we'll have to wait for the next book
to see what happens next if you want to
truly appreciate the message and the
mysteries of this story you've got to
check out the books as well as the main
series there's the world book and fire
and blood and the dunk and egg stories
and you can get any one of these on
audiobook for free right now by signing
up for a trial with audible members get
an audiobook each month and if you
cancel you keep the audiobooks you can
listen in the car or the gym or while
you sail from EEB to ash I sign up at
audible.com slash ASX many thanks to the
artists links are all below and check
out the linked essays and videos for
more on Iran
this video topic was chosen by
supporters on patreon
thanks to patrons Nolan Stroud Kenneth
weeks Jess Simpson John Padgett Michelle
canavero Lowe Scarlett Farrokh and Timur
Cheers
you